c'est par hasard que cette pellicule de
8 mm s'est retrouvé entre mes mains
nous sommes entre 1963 et 1965 à damas
et s'il y avait des photos
d'installations militaires je les
regardais de nombreuses fois un homme
posant près de monuments une vieille
affiche de la première du film
hollywoodien ville sans pitié et une
bagarre au marché
j'avais des doutes devaient perdre mon
temps avec tout ça mais je revenais à
cette pellicule encore et encore pour
retracer une séquence d'événements ce
qu'il se passait en syrie à cette époque
qui travaillait là bas c'était mon grand
père qu'il me berçais qui me tenait sur
ses genoux il me mettant bien la
curiosité comme une machine à mouvement
perpétuel
elle ne s'arrête jamais et puis soudain
je les ai vus stop
regardons encore une fois maintenant au
ralenti
c'est elie cohen un espion que certains
considèrent comme un héros national et
d'autres comme un véritable sedera le
007 israélien a nié il pointe du doigt
ce démons de l'enfer et 10 c'est lui qui
a fait tout cela
[Musique]
personne n'aurait jamais vu ce film si
ce n'était grâce à un vieil ami à moi un
collectionneur de saint pétersbourg
alexei markov il a un flair incroyable
pour les antiquités
un jour il m'a demandé de venir à son
magasin d'antiquités pour me montrer
quelques objets provenant d'un
appartement à vendre
les propriétaires se débarrasser des
choses dont ils n'avaient plus besoin
dans le temps ce qui était écrit sur les
boîtes attiré mon attention il n'y avait
qu'un seul mot syrie ils ont remis les
boîtes à alexei avec une vieille caméra
disons vous pouvez le prendre
nous n'en avons pas besoin quand nous
avons trouvé les pellicules nous avions
très envie de les regarder
elle était fille une petite impossible
de distinguer quoi que ce soit à même en
les examinant à contre jour
ainsi la bd photo d'installations
militaires et puis nous avons dû trouver
l'appareil nécessaire les temps changent
et tout est devenu numérique
quand compagne en avons trouvé un dans
un magasin d'antiquités et l'avons
acheté mais ça n'a pas marché
l'appareil n'était pas bon en avant
d'acheter un autre on a assemblé un
appareil à partir des deux et on a
réussi à mettre en marche cette machine
qui crépitent et la pellicule cassez
dont nous devions la réparer tout le
temps on a dû surmonter tous ces
problèmes là on n'a pas trouvé à quoi on
s'attendait
rien d'intéressant
la séquence vidéo n'était pas
impressionnant donc nous avons suggéré
que tu t'en charge parce que nous on
avait plus de ressources
c'est comme ça que j'ai eus ces
pellicules
il était écrit à la main sur les boîtes
b loukine pas à pas j'ai commencé à
démêler cette histoire j'ai lu dans un
vieux répertoire de leningrad
qu'autrefois trois personnes vivaient
dans cet appartement
boris loukine né en 1918 sa femme sonia
et leur petite fille yulia
boris et oya était mort j'ai donc trouvé
ioulia et cette photo sur les réseaux
sociaux
c'était la première pièce du puzzle
c'était certainement boris loukine
l'homme qui avait filmé le vieux damas
enregistrant elie cohen sur cette
pellicule
[Musique]
c'était mon grand père qui me berçais
qui me tenait sur ses genoux il me
mettant il ne l'avait jamais la voix une
héroïne je ne les ai jamais entendu
crier gauche en gros je ne les ai jamais
vus perdre son sang froid
il me disait toujours essaie d'éviter
les conflits codes complexes
quand mon grand père est mort en 2008
j'ai eu du mal à entrer dans cet
appartement il me semblait que quelqu'un
m'appelait que j'entendais savoir où la
voix de ma grand-mère peut-être c'est
pour ça que nous avons décidé de vendre
cet appartement
cette partie
quiconque qui a déjà déménagé c'est que
quelque chose lui échappera certainement
quels types de caméras s'éteignent et je
ne m'en souviens pas mais je me souviens
que c'était un grand apparaît qui est
claqué comme ça ta ta ta ta ta ta ta il
était comme ça et il tournait la
manivelle
j'ai trouvé des secrets d'attribution de
décoration militaire au nom de look in
sur le site du ministère de la défense
du lia a confirmé que son grand père
était militaire il a été dans l'armée
pendant toute la durée de la guerre et
on lui a décerné trois fois à l'ordre de
l'étoile rouge
il ne portait jamais ses décorations il
n'apportait que des distinctions
militaires mais il en avait vraiment une
belle collection
il ne m'est pas se vanter il ne
racontaient jamais comment il avait eu
ces médailles après la fin de la guerre
boris loukine est sorti diplômé de
l'académie militaire à leningrad et a
été envoyé en syrie dans les années 1960
il est devenu en professionnels de haut
niveau dans les domaines des systèmes de
communications militaires mais à chaque
fois que ioulia demandé à son grand-père
ce qu'il faisait en syrie il esquive et
éviter de répondre
il ne m'a jamais raconté ce qu'il
faisait ces années là au lieu de
répondre
il commença à faire des blagues trois ou
quatre minutes plus tard j'oubliais ma
question et on rit ensemble on s'amusait
c'était tout je veux dire il était
prudent ce sujet il ne voulait pas en
parler semble-t-il on peut être qu'il ne
pouvait simplement pas le faire bien sûr
que je suis curieuse de savoir ce qui
s'est passé en syrie mais j'ai peur en
même temps qui sait ce qu'on peut
apprendre
je ne sais pas mais je suis toujours
curieuse oui c'est ce que nous essayons
de découvrir
[Musique]
loukine est arrivé à damas au moment où
il y à un ben saul cohen connu sous le
nom d'elie cohen il travaillait notre
homme à damas comme l'appelait le mossad
l' agence de renseignement israélienne
loué un appartement dans le centre ville
juste en face de l'état major du
ministère syrien de la défense
ils pouvaient surveiller tous les
déplacements des hauts responsables
militaires syriens
[Musique]
c'est la vidéo que l'officier des
troupes de transmission soviétique boris
loukine a réalisé en 1963 une caméra
vidéo crown fabriqués au japon la
compagnie pendant son séjour
si cette même caméra
[Musique]
tout amateur de cinéma en urss ne
pouvait que rêver d'en avoir une
[Musique]
l'étui en cuir à conserver son état
d'origine
[Musique]
en 1963
boris ne pouvait même pas imaginer qu'il
avait réussi à filmer
maurice loukine à 45 ans en costume
sombre une pince à cravate en laiton et
une chemise blanche pas d'insigne
l'union soviétique ne divulguer ni
l'ampleur de l'assistance ni les types
de spécialistes qu'elle envoie ce sont
des collègues de travail de look in d
officier soviétique urss accroît
progressivement son aide militaire à la
syrie en 1963 il y avait au moins 150
conseillers militaires
le mossad était au courant de la
présence de boris loukine et d'autres
spécialistes sur le territoire syrien
dès leur arrivée 50 personnes
le résident du service de renseignement
israélien elie cohen faisait
parfaitement son travail et a été
félicité à plusieurs reprises par ses
supérieurs pour avoir transmis des
informations sur l'assistance militaire
soviétique
c'était sa première tâche
la seconde consistait à recueillir des
informations sur les positions des
troupes syriennes au milieu des années
plusieurs agences de renseignement se
sont engagés dans une bataille décisive
pour la syrie comme tout le moyen-orient
le pays était au milieu de la
répartition des sphères d'influencé
entre l'otan et le pacte de varsovie
d'un syrie essayer de se démarquer
tandis que les deux camps tenté de
l'attirer vers eux les coups d'état se
sont succédé il y avait même une
expression au sein de la direction
générale des renseignements du ministère
de la défense de l'urss
le nombre de coups d'état en syrie
correspondait à la formule n plus
or personne ne savait quand le prochain
coup d'état aurait lieu en mars 1963 le
parti baas est arrivé au pouvoir
la syrie est devenue en alliés de l'urss
ce fut une victoire des services de
renseignement soviétique à la devise du
parti de la résurrection arabe
socialiste et lydie unités liberté
socialisme salle izzo regardez l'ordre
des mots la nation arabe est unie et sa
mission est éternel
tous les arabes de l'atlantique à
l'océan indien doivent être unis à
peines et d'un disque week end
sergei était tout petit quand il est
arrivé à damas avec son père léonid
medvedko officiellement journalistes
pour tass officieusement agents du
renseignement soviétique et c'est de son
père un agent soviétique qu'il a obtenu
ses premières connaissances de la syrie
en raison de l'expiration du délai de
prescription il est possible d'en parler
publiquement à nier ils ont annoncé une
politique anti impérialiste il était
contre les états unis contre la france
et le royaume uni
il se posait également à israël c'est
pour ça qu'ils étaient nos alliés
cependant la syrie n'a pas renoncé au
bien de la civilisation occidentale
cela se voit clairement dans les vidéos
de boris loukine il y avait des voitures
américaines britanniques et françaises
dans les rues de damas conduite par des
diplomates ainsi que des agents de
renseignement et des spécialistes
militaires
les spécialistes militaires soviétiques
former une caste spécifiques
ils étaient tous très expérimentés ils
avaient fait leur preuve à plusieurs
reprises pas un seul renégats tout au
long de l'histoire
macha spécialistes et nos spécialistes
étaient des techniciens experts amis ils
maîtrisaient les moteurs et machines les
armes à rouge et leur nombre et leurs
spécialités ont été établis par le
commandement local
les salaires étaient assez important
pour l'époque de 1000 à 1200 dollars par
mois 10 à 12 fois plus que la moyenne en
urss ont six mois on pouvait gagner
assez pour acquérir une volga la plus
prestigieuse voiture soviétique
nos spécialistes militaires non
seulement former le personnel des forces
armées syriennes d assurer également la
maintenance du matériel
des véhicules blindés des chars t 34 des
voitures 1110 stasi si les arabes les
ont tous maîtrisés très vite dans cette
vidéo tournée par boris luchino voit
également des spécialistes militaires
soviétiques les médias étrangers essayer
de flanquer la trouille en disant que
tous les spécialistes soviétique étaient
des espions
bien sûr ce n'était pas vrai c'était des
gens qui venaient de toute l'union
soviétique des professionnels de très
haut niveau
le personnel du service de transmission
était d'une valeur particulière
voorhees loukine travailler dans un
domaine très vulnérable chez les syriens
aujourd'hui il est difficile de dire à
quel point il était impliqué dans les
opérations de renseignement soviétique
mais il est clair qu'il travaillait avec
des agents soviétiques et s'y
connaissait en émetteurs et en tout ce
qui concerne l'interception de signaux
il avait besoin de gens de bons
spécialistes et les syriens ne possédait
pas toujours les équipements requis pour
faire face à ceux d'israël tel sommet
notamment pour ce qui était du matériel
radio et des radios goniomètre bien sûr
elie cohen essayer d'être le plus
prudent possible mais c'était aussi un
homme passionné il vivait à damas sous
pseudonyme et ils pensaient qu'ils
n'avaient pas à être trop scrupuleux
quant aux moyens qu'ils utilisent et ou
aux relations qu'il se faisait
oui mais n'diaye choisi comme on a là
affaire un homme purement orientales ce
tout qui a grandi dans un milieu arabe
dans le monde arabe voit la passe comme
idée niveau accepte son père venait
d'alep en syrie il signa et sa famille
parlait un dialecte syrien d'y aller
accès qu il était juif d'origine no hay
al mais il a grandi dans le monde arabe
qu'il connaissait très bien mais je
crois que c'est ça le secret de son
succès rivaux ou spear ils étaient
grands beaux riches et ceux qui a son
importance c'était une personne
charmante il gagnait facilement les
coeurs toutes les portes lui était
ouverte
[Musique]
il a entamé son chemin vers les bureaux
des hauts fonctionnaires syrien dans la
lointaine argentine
cohen a misé sur l'attaché militaire
syrien amin al hafez ils sont devenus
amis à buenos aires est ce à la suite de
la révolution de mars 1963
cet homme est rentré dans son pays natal
et en est devenu le président cohen
était toujours là
[Musique]
il appliquait les tactiques approprié
parfois des cadeaux parfois de l'argent
ou alors il pouvait glisser un mot
quelque part pour aider quelqu'un
il employait de vieilles méthodes pour
ainsi dire bien connu se servaient des
femmes il avait toutes les clés pour sa
carrière
son jeu était très dangereux mais
c'était fascinant il le jouet si
sincèrement que comme on dit il ya des
artistes qui jouent et il ya ceux qui
vivent
il était l'un de ceux qui vivent leur
rôle cohen était proche des plus hautes
autorités syriennes comme en témoigne
cette célèbre photo de lui debout sur le
toit de la résidence du premier ministre
la rumeur disait qu'il aurait même pu
devenir ministre syrien de la défense et
avec le temps président aucun autre
espion au monde n'a probablement atteint
de tels sommets
il y avait une autre tâche que le mossad
a confié à elie cohen identifier et
éliminer les criminels de guerre nazis
qui après la seconde guerre mondiale
avaient fui l'europe pour s'installer
aux états-unis au canada au royaume-uni
et au moyen-orient notamment en syrie
selon certaines sources que j'ai pu lire
quelques 150 officiers nazis ont trouvé
refuge dans les pays arabes et surtout
en syrie et la plupart étaient pour
ainsi dire tout simplement tu as des
criminels et des assassins pottas mouche
tôt il savait qu historiquement les
allemands avaient fait la guerre contre
la france et la france et le royaume uni
étaient ceux qui avaient occupé les
territoires arabes les pays arabes
astral
donc les arabes se frottait joyeusement
les mains en se disant formidable
maintenant les allemands vont nous aider
à nous libérer
mathon à l'époque les syriens avaient
une position très anti israël
[Musique]
israël doit être balayé dans la mer
israël n'a pas le droit d'exister
tous les juifs doivent être éliminés il
n'avait aucun problème avec les juifs en
tant que peuple
beaucoup de gens avaient des amis juifs
je le sais par ma propre expérience ici
d'un côté de la rue vie mohamed là bas
de l'autre côté habite michel nous
vivons tous ensemble dans la vieille
ville comme des frères nous célébrons
les mariages ensemble nous pleurons nos
amis décédés ensemble nous nous
entraidons toujours nous sommes syrien
nous sommes frères mais pour ce qui est
de l'idéologie ou de la politique c'est
tout à fait différent lorsque
l'idéologie du sionisme a été conçue
elle était assez agressive et jugé
absolument inacceptable
ainsi le sionisme et le judaïsme sont
deux choses différentes pour les arabes
je parle là des arabes raisonnable et
éduqué dans ce criminel de guerre ont
tenté d'exploiter cette discorde en
syrie il était la cible principale des
services de renseignements israéliens en
syrie comme partout dans le monde onu
franz rademacher était censée éliminer
tous les juifs y capte fabrique
ils ont une piste concernant franz
rademacher immédiatement après
l'arrestation de l'ancien nazi adolf
eichmann le mossad a secrètement enlevé
et schumann d'argentine où il vivait
sous un autre nom et l'ont emmené à tel
aviv pour le juger ce fut alors une
grande victoire pour les services de
renseignements israéliens pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale eichmann et
rades marcheurs ont participé à
l'élaboration du plan madagascar visant
à déplacer les juifs d'europe
deux ans après le procès après
l'exécution des chemins d'un tel aviv
elie cohen a retrouvé raz-de-marée
heures à damas il vivait sous le
pseudonyme de rosello cohen en a informé
tel aviv
demain je vais chez rosello vous me
recevait rosello c'est franz rademacher
je conviens
cohen a préparé un cadeau pour l'ancien
officier nazi franz rademacher une
lettre piégée mais la tentative
d'assassinât a échoué
quelque chose n'a pas marché a été
blessé il a perdu quelques noix si je ne
m'abuse c'est devenu une sorte de marque
pour identifier cet homme certains
disent que c'est à cause de cette
mission particulière que l'agent du
mossad à damas elie cohen a été placé
sous la surveillance étroite des
services spéciaux syrien mais il n'y
avait aucune preuve directe de son
implication dans la tentative
d'assassinât
quant à rades marc heures il a été
arrêté fin 1963 à damas et accusé
d'espionnage au profit de l'allemagne de
l'ouest et ce malgré le fait qu'il était
un farouche opposant à israël ce qui
faisait de lui un ami de la syrie mais
les intérêts du bloc occidental aller à
l'encontre de la position officielle de
damas qui cherchait un rapprochement
avec l'urss raz-de-marée heures a
ensuite été libéré pour raison médicale
et s'est rendu volontairement aux
autorités de la république fédérale
d'allemagne
l'officier soviétique boris loukine a vu
les événements de ce complot sophistiqué
se déroulait alors qu'il était en poste
en syrie
nos protagonistes pouvait se creuser à
n'importe quel moment dans le centre de
damas
et si on tient compte du fait qu'il s'y
sont trouvés en même temps pendant
environ trois ans il est fort probable
que cela se soit effectivement produit
c'est dans la vieille ville que boris
loukine a utilisé la plupart de ces
pellicules de 8 mm et un jour quand il a
mis en marche sa caméra il a filmé cet
homme là on va regarder au ralenti
encore une fois
je suis sûr que la vieille ville et l
endroit préféré de l'espion israélien et
je suis convaincu que c'était un vrai
plaisir pour lui de marché dans les rues
de ces quartiers historiques la journée
de l'agent israélien elie cohen commencé
à 8h30
il a allumé la radio pour écouter des
chansons en arabe diffusé à la demande
des auditeurs le mossad transmettait
ainsi des données relatives à une
nouvelle mission
l'introduction de chaque chanson
contenait des parties du code
son plus grand succès a été de
transmettre des informations secrètes
sur la position des troupes syriennes
sur le plateau du golan
c'était l'emplacement stratégique clé là
où la syrie pouvait anéantir israël et
inversement
l'enseignant il a mis à nu le plateau du
golan pour les israéliens
cohen avait réussi à s'y rendre avec
quelqu'un d'aussi haut placées que le
fils du chef d'état major
ou peut-être un autre militaire de haut
niveau il conduisait une voiture de
sport
il passe alors temps ensemble draguer
les filles excusez moi mais il savait
être un fêtard un playboy quand c'est
nécessaire
à d'autres moments il se faisait
philosophes historiens et comme il se
présentait en sommes bien éduqué en
personne cultivée qui pouvait entretenir
une conversation sur les perles de la
littérature arabe les transmissions de
renseignement à tel aviv par cohen créer
des interférences radios pour les
auditeurs dans son quartier
les services secrets syriens ont
commencé à recevoir des plaintes des
membres du personnel des ambassades
situées à proximité
silly stuff
les syriens avaient assez d'équipements
pour comprendre que quelque chose
clochait qu'il y avait une fuite
il le savait mais il ne pouvait pas
comprendre qui en était à l'origine
et comment cela se déroulait exactement
à cork en janvier 1965
l'agent de renseignement israélien elie
cohen a été démasqué par les services
spéciaux mais ce ne sont pas les syriens
qu'ils ont repéré
ils ont demandé de l'aide à nos experts
qui ont apporté leurs équipements
c'était plus pour former des gens ils y
sont allés pour faire le travail
ils ont précisé le secteur est
finalement réussi à déterminer
l'emplacement exact est comme il
s'adonne au jeu
la suite tout le monde la connaît
quelques soldats et plusieurs hommes en
civil sont entrés dans l'appartement de
cohen juste moment où il se servait de
la radio pour transmettre des
informations à tel aviv
cohen a été pris en flagrant délit
heroes et cycliques ils menacent pong il
a été détecté avec un équipement
soviétique qui a été expédiée du rss la
demande de la série des conseils aux
hommes qui étaient présents en syrie à
ce moment là que des spécialistes en
radio électronique en opération de ce
genre ne sont pas restés à l'écart bien
sûr il était également présent
cohen a été condamné à la peine capitale
par pendaison pour avoir causé des
dommages irréparables à la syrie en
israël
il est considéré comme un héros tel aviv
s'est battu pour son extradition
ils ont utilisé tous les moyens
diplomatiques possibles
les chefs de plusieurs états sont
intervenus en sa faveur y compris la
reine d'angleterre est le pape mais les
autorités syriennes étaient déterminés
ils s'étaient la guerre et cohen était
en ennemis de la syrie
son exécution à damas a été retransmise
en direct cohen a été pendu sur la place
al marj r mais ce jeudi a longtemps été
choisi comme lieu de telles exécutions
elle peut accueillir plusieurs milliers
de personnes
loubier
[Musique]
son corps il a été exposé pendant
quelques temps i
assez longtemps pour que les gens
répondent la nouvelle dépêchez vous il
faut aller voir ça je me souviens
comment le chauffeur de mon père alfred
est venu en courant monsieur leonid
monsieur leonid cohen a été pendu allons
voir ça
le cercueil de l'espion a été emporté
vers une destination inconnue
israël tente depuis lors d'obtenir le
retour de ces cendres
[Musique]
il n'y a aucune preuve directe que boris
look in a personnellement joué un rôle
dans la capture de cohen ou que c'est
lui qui a réduit la zone de recherche ou
qu'il était dans la voiture qui
parcouraient la ville
bien sûr que non les boris loukine était
à damas à cette époque il exerçait ses
fonctions d'officier du service de
transmission mais son voyage en syrie
s'est terminée en 1965 l'année où cohen
adversaire sérieux de la syrie et de
l'union soviétique a été exécuté
[Musique]
s'il mène à votre team la série était le
pays avec lequel l'union soviétique
avait décidé d'être alliés à long terme
yahoo davos et ils ont réussi
je dois vous dire qu'en fin de compte la
série a survécu grâce à cela ce n'était
pas seulement une coopération sur la
base de raisons politiques
cela se passait déjà au niveau des
peuples et sicce spécialistes ici des
milliers d'experts des milliers de
syriens qui venaient chez nous pour
faire leurs études
des milliers de syriens qui se sont
mariés à des femmes russes des
militaires et des civils
il s'agit de pas moins de trente mille
citoyens russes ont syrie la syrie et je
le répète encore et encore est un pays
très particulier pour le peuple russe et
nous avons beaucoup à y perdre
pendant que je reconstituer le cours des
événements du milieu des années 1960
cette vieille affiche dans le film
tourné par boris loukine surgissait de
temps en temps dans ma tête ville sans
pitié c'était bien ce que damas était
devenu pour l'agent israélien elie cohen